I was actually pretty nervous to talk in
class when I would do like presentations
the first time I ever talked on stage it
was 1500 people so I went from like
nervous to speak in front of a high
school class the next time I spoke in
public was in front of a thousand plus
people and I wasn't nervous that time
and it was because when I was talking to
high school I was talking about stuff
that I didn't know about you're making
it up as you go you've crammed the night
before you're talking about like Thomas
Jefferson's cousin whatever it was
something I didn't care about and I
didn't know about so I was afraid of
looking like a fool that's been probably
a perspective that I've taken for most
things I talk on is I just try and talk
on things that I have done so no one can
really poke holes in it